today's Monday August eighteenth and
you're watching gamespot news I'm Chris
waters here fillion for Jess McDonald as
she spends the week in river lon lifting
barrels with her mind and getting
hollered at by fish vendors some people
just have all the luck you know and what
do you and I have news the recently
released sacred three has not been well
received especially by fans of the
series and now one of the members of the
development team has spoken out about it
on the subject of why the game turned
out poorly former team games junior game
designer Sasha wagon trot said the
marketing department of deep silver was
the only one with enough power to change
the direction of the franchise and
change it did from an action RPG to a
mindless hack and slash er according to
GameSpot's review which rated sacred 3 a
4 out of 10 Sam with the launch of
destiny just three weeks away one of the
writers of the game has traded in moon
Wizards for White Walkers Joshua Rubin
who spent two years at bungie writing
the story for destiny has quit the
studio to take a job at telltale games
where he would work on the developers
Game of Thrones episodic series Rubin
announced the news on Twitter saying
he's excited by the challenge of writing
a game of thrones story that is on par
or better than what fans found in the
HBO TV show now I can only assume that
by better than he means the series will
finally make the much-awaited turn to
focus entirely on Arya Stark and now she
time again for our recurring news time
feature executive reassurances first up
Phil Spencer from Microsoft on rise of
the tomb Raider's timed Xbox exclusivity
it doesn't come from an evil space it
comes from a space where there's an
opportunity that maps really well with
what we need in terms of the genre and a
partner that's looking for a partnership
other people can do the deal but it was
a deal that fit well with us and I think
it could help the franchise in the long
run and help crystal and square and us
now that's reassuring
next up Andrew Wilson from EA on
listening to their customers we haven't
always been great listeners but we're
getting better and what that's telling
us is that people want choice they want
to be able to choose what's right for
them at a given moment in time there
isn't a one-size-fits-all any longer
we've got to build a core platform game
engines and games that facilitate that
well doesn't that just put your mind at
ease see you next time on executive
reassurances that's all the news we've
got from San Francisco today tomorrow
it's come at you from London and Lucy
James is going to be covering the news
duties as I take on the lobby Danny
might be back he might not be but
there's going to be a lot of cool games
maybe some giveaways general good times
2 p.m. pacific come see me there